um i have worked out okay here's an
advantage if you decide that you're
trans
and you're posh and the property is
going to the mail in the family
otherwise the whole estate goes right to
the cousin then you can say i'm trans i
can keep the estate well this is i i i
is that possible i don't see why not
well i i do think martina rattle over
said you know that the number 300 male
tennis player if he wanted to transition
either legitimately or to cheat could do
so without having any surgery and would
just reduce their testosterone level but
not their physical body mass and become
the greatest tennis player in history on
the women's side and then three years
later go back to are you interviewing me
or am i interviewing you because you're
doing all the talking
okay can i just no let me say something
say something right honestly
i've only got 15 minutes but the amount
of
trans who actually have surgery is
minuscule yeah
so actually i don't know about this um
trans in this particular case but it's
so easy
i could suddenly decide to be a male
athlete when you see politicians who
can't answer what is a woman yeah a what
do you feel about that what is the
answer the answer is a woman is someone
with a vagina do you need to say that
again it is somebody with a vagina
and i can now be cancelled well a woman
every dictionary will say is an adult
female adult human female that's it it's
not complicated but they don't say that
i think it's so disappointing when the
leader of the labour party always has to
sink for three weeks before he makes
that decision on anything
just mumbling yvette cooper the same i
don't want to be drawn into that
it it is so unfair it is so it is the
first time we've never been able to have
a debate you and i are having one here
yes because we're fearless
but
name me when the last debate was on the
bbc about trans well when you see what
happened to jk rowling yeah this is what
puts people off because you know she's
been absolutely terrorized yeah i
interviewed a trans activist this week
and well i just played a little clip of
just to remind the viewers of what
happened but it was pretty unpleasant
experience
we don't want these people coming in and
standing next to this this icon of
feminism they are appropriating the
imagery of the suffragette movement a
movement for women's liberation and and
rebranding it as this hateful movement
against trans people and we don't stand
for that and the majority of women the
majority of feminists don't stand for
i mean
the trans activists then went on to uh
hurl abuse at me and counsel they call
you a nasty name they did something you
cry
i know i'm absolutely as you know i'm
sure you didn't i'm a bit like you it
doesn't stick some stones is my kind of
mantra but
what i was struck by was the venom that
came with it and i've seen it applying
to jk rowling and i've seen it to this
young skateboarder taylor silverman when
she went public the abuse that she got
from the trans community was appalling
on social media why are they so angry
you see i don't understand why haven't
we got a trans person here who will
argue with us sensibly yeah there is no
debate and trying to reach a point of
consensus right yeah yeah let me ask you
about something else that was in the
news today i thought of you immediately
do you think of me often i do think of
you often simply now i've seen you now
that i've said you're good looking
exactly yeah uh no because actually we
go back a long way and also we both
worked at the daily mirror for many
years
who crossed the divide to become
television get on with it exactly what
were you going to say the the uk today
had the biggest ever lottery winners 184
million people they're not as rich as
you are well i'm going to come to your
wealth in a minute let's just see what
they had to say watch this
jess hadn't had a great night's sleep so
i thought do i wake her up don't i wake
her up what what do i do so i just sat
there for a minute
trying to take it all in and i thought
well i'll give her because it's only 20
minutes i'll give her an extra 20
minutes till her alarm goes off
so he waited 20 minutes after knowing he
won 184 million didn't want to wake his
wife up um what i was struck by when i
watched that and i because i knew you
were coming on yeah it's the old thing
are they going to be happy
with 184 million there'll be loads of
people right now suffering from the
economic crisis go of course they will
but so many of these lottery winners
actually find that when they get the
grass it's not greener and it's so much
better to give money to people who've
already got money because they're
trained like you me
and you appear but does it bring
happiness i mean it obviously stops the
the agony and turmoil of not having
money which is an appalling thing for
people but does having a lot of money
hundreds of millions do you think that
kind of wealth in your experience of
meeting very wealthy people and being
well off yourself does it bring
happiness not necessarily but i think
i'd rather be miserable and rich right
than miserable and poor wouldn't yeah
well i think yeah i think poverty is the
worst thing you can experience as a
human being because to not be able to
feed your children so is the worst thing
but i have met a lot of wealthy people
who are miserable and boring and they
always want more there's always somebody
around who's got more and also you've
been in los angeles as much as i have
you find they have these huge houses and
they all live in one tiny room yes and
they watch the television and the rest
of the house looks like the four seasons
everything's beige
and they never use it what advice would
you give these lottery winners 184
million to spend well i'd give them time
actually they need time
and they keep they need so stephen
daldry once said to me when he'd become
uh quite rich from his first movie billy
elliot uh he said if you're looking
after relatives
never give them a set amount every year
or always make them worry they might not
get anything from you next year
what do you make of of cancel culture of
this this
well i don't know
do you do you accept it you accept it it
has to exist i couldn't because you
don't care no it doesn't cost me any
money does it if anyone cancels me
right and you're not on social media
right you don't do any of it no why
well no one's paying me to do that
why would i do it but what do you think
the people i find it amazing in a
democracy like the uk for example or
america these great bastions of
democracy people are terrified of saying
what they think now well in case they
get destroyed but you are never off your
phone i watched you in rehearsal right
you're doing a bit of rehearsal and
you're back on your phone and you do a
lot of social media well it's also a
great research tool obviously i was
checking in but you also you're a big
emailer yes yeah
and you're on twitter presumably yes
yeah and you do instagram yes okay do
you mind being cult
do you mind being cancelled well it's
funny i had a little experience of it of
good morning
but i lost my job on good morning
britain for expressing an honestly held
opinion what a great great future you
suddenly have yeah it was a great career
move but actually in the moment i was
pretty appalled that i i was not able to
express myself honestly and had to then
depart a job i loved i found it a weird
new phenomenon but do you know what
pierce the nation cried
[Laughter]
you know i'm quite proud of you because
people are incredibly fond of you
because you're fearless thank you yeah
you don't know what to say can we give
anne a bit more time please i'm ready i
think it's the interview's beginning to
really go the way i hoped
what else do you want to embarrass me
about what do you want i tell you what
i'll ask you about the the platinum
jubilee coming up with the queen and
she's a remarkable woman isn't she our
entire lives did we have one monarch
what do you feel about her what do you
feel about the monarchy what's going to
happen when she's no longer with us i
think actually the kate and william
thing is very lucky i i watched i saw
the pictures of um why do we still call
her kate middleton i don't know actually
i didn't really call her i told duchess
of cambridge yeah yeah but everyone does
still call her code middleton um
that that she has been terrific too
haven't they
um
they've just stepped in and we're fond
of them and they seem to do the right
you watch them tonight at the tom cruise
premiere and they are they're just a
class actor yeah they are and they
understand i think they're kind of less
is more the you know don't give big
whiny interviews i mean obviously the
comparison is harry and megan who just
seemed to have gone completely rogue
i mean they do back apparently for the
jubilee what do you what do you think
i don't think they'll be at the jubilee
i mean i don't know why they don't
understand they're living in this
socking great house i mean you and i
could sit at home doing video calls
saying you know please help the poor
today i'm not actually getting off my
backside
i find the hypocrisy is what greats and
also using the royal titles yeah to make
themselves very rich
and then trashing the royals and the
institution afforded them the titles i'm
wondering whether megan will find
another step up is there anyone greater
than what is the next step you think i
don't know if there is one
megan is what i call last in the queue
first on the bus
[Laughter]
before i let you go you've left
countdown which a lot of fans will be
very upset about you would guess you
were brilliant on it i read the sort of
tea leaves it looked like
people weren't getting on great would
that be fair all of you no i think i
mean
susie dent is great um rachel riley is a
completely brilliant at the uh maths you
just didn't get on well no i didn't not
get on but some performers like a lot of
noise around them before they go on air
and others like me who are trying to get
the contestants to remember what their
hobbies are
would would like some quirk while she's
doing that not two minutes so it was
important to me that we took her mic off
so that um i could have what i love
about you is many things but you you're
fearless i love your outspokenness i
love the interviews you give they always
make me laugh but they also inspire me
because you've got a tremendous work
ethic and what i guess the obvious
question what what are you gonna do next
you got any ideas i thought um if you
upset them here i could just move in
[Laughter]
you know what we could take you and talk
tv you'd be fantastic yeah it's money is
the money good enough
look at this suit yeah
and lovely to see you so good looking a
real pleasure thank you you can come
back can we book down immediately for
next week uh it's lovely to see you
looking fantastic and it's always a joy
to have you really appreciate it